new in theaters this weekend Stuber and
crawl what will you see this is your
weekend ticket
[Music]
please be a five-star ID let's go
what do you have a more specific address
open stop yelling neighborhoods that's
not how unlikely buddy cop comedy Stuber
comes out this weekend Stu played by
Kumail Nanjiani is a nervous
mild-mannered uber driver making his
usual rounds just trying to keep his
five-star score when unfortunately his
next bear turns out to be Vick played by
Dave Bautista a tough detective in hot
pursuit of a ruthless terrorist who is
now tasked with driving Vic into
increasingly dangerous situations and
must step up his bravery or he might get
hurt or worse yet get a one-star rating
takeaway for you before I got shot this
rhetorical rhetorical question gave this
movies for you if you're looking for a
comedy to check out this weekend you
like the comedy chops of Kumail Nanjiani
or Dave Bautista or if you feel like the
scariest part of all that is having to
talk to your goober driver do one of my
uber drivers had the craziest dubstep
that I've ever heard
I go to festivals all the time and I was
just like whoa I didn't know this type
existed like Skrillex would have been
like can you please turn that down
[Music]
what happened
[Music]
and lastly crawl comes to theaters this
weekend Crona is about some big ole
alligators I'm getting ahead of myself
amidst a huge Florida hurricane a young
woman named hailey Braves the
increasingly dangerous conditions to
seek out her missing father while she
does find him trapped and injured she
unfortunately finds something else you
guessed it some big ol alligators now
Hayley and her father must escape a
flooded house the massive hurricane and
also these guys crawl is produced by Sam
Raimi who's known for some pretty fun
filmmaking and stories so it's sure to
be a hell of a ride
this movie is for you if you're looking
for an edge of your seat suspense movie
this weekend you're down for some
r-rated monster type gore or if you're
just generally afraid of big ol
alligators actually producer Scott is
parked big ol alligator than that right
no but I do wear Crocs that is your
weekend ticket will you see and check
back next week for
[Music]